normalerweise funktioniert das doch so
gut bei edeka älterer herr mit cooler
kappe oder brille macht werbung
doch sie finden die neue werbung gar
nicht geil 300 trecker vor einem edeka
lager in niedersachsen sechs stunden
belagerung ein ziel das plakat muss weg
ausgedacht hat sich bei jedem einzelnen
von uns entschuldigen
die bauern wehren sich gegen dumping
preise bei lebensmitteln essen hat einen
preis verdient den niedrigsten steht auf
dem plakat erika verramscht unsere
lebensmittel
es ist ein schlag ins gesicht für uns
alle bauern
wir lieben unsere lebensmittel und wir
wollen auch weiter für euch arbeiten und
wir wollen aber gerne auch weiter davon
existieren können die landwirte
verstehen den werbeslogan als
provokation nach monatelangen bauern
demos gegen niedrigpreise und das agrar
paket
es dauert nicht lange und auf twitter
rollt ein shitstorm los beschissener
kampagne unerträglich auch
bundespolitiker steigen ein kampagne
beenden
widerlich und von vorgestern die nerven
liegen blank antwort edeka bei dem
plakat handle es sich um ein
missverständnis ziel der
marketingkampagne war es alle
ortschaften wie zum beispiel auf mieten
oder bremen in unserem absatzgebiet
individuell anzusprechen
es war somit eindeutig der ort essen
oldenburg gemeint und nicht essen im
sinne von lebensmitteln
dieses essen douwes doppeldeutige
deutsche sprache werbung für niedrige
lebensmittelpreise in berlin oder bergen
klingen nun ja eindeutig nicht nach
billig essen
na dann ist jetzt wieder ruhe im stall
ich persönlich finde das thema von edeka
heute sehr schwach
uns ist auch bewusst dass die jedes
jeden ort an sich gemeint haben aber es
geht einfach um die lebensmittelpreise
da im allgemeinen wir haben auch gut
deutschland einfach die schnauze voll
und vom handel vorführen zu lassen
dicke hat die plakate in der region
mittlerweile entfernen lassen
ziemlicher pr super-gau statt
geil
dich